oh hi guys i am at Macworld now you
might hear a little echo that's because
I'm in the youtube booth check this out
you too yeah it's pretty awesome show
you but it's I got this thing like
bolted down so there's like the outside
of the booth there's people walking
around and then over here they have oh
there's someone taking pictures up like
and then there's at this side probably
you know like self some alarm to live in
public it's not there there's like a
bunch of little demos going on there's
an earpick awesome application they just
launched for just exciting so it's
always good for Windows and it's a lot
faster than iPhoto so Mac users usually
check it out Windows users you probably
already have it so that's it I'm here
Matt we're all I'm having a great time
and this YouTube booth
anyway that's it that's all of that get
some good coffee here net world's great
having a good time yes tomorrow morn
that's Thursdays
you